Jamie used to ask for Adam's advice. But he didn't want Adam's advice. Back in high school, they would go on these long walks, and Jamie would tell Adam, his best friend, about his various crushes. The crushes were usually on girls who shared two particular qualities. Number one, they were usually really, really pretty. And number two, they had no interest in Jamie, whatsoever.
杰米过去常寻求亚当的建议。但他并不想要亚当的建议。还在高中的时候，他们会一起漫步很久，杰米会向他最好的朋友亚当倾诉他各种暗恋的对象。这些暗恋对象通常有两个共同点。第一，她们通常都非常、非常漂亮。第二，她们对杰米完全没有任何兴趣。
He'd say like, God, I spent the weekend with Jung. And I kept on wanting to kiss her. But I couldn't kiss her. And every time I thought I could go and kiss her, she'd say, you know, I really think I want to go out with Hampton. And he would say, what should I do? She wants me to go this party next week. Should I go?
他会说，天哪，我周末和琼待在一起。我一直想吻她。但我无法吻她。而且每次我觉得我可以去吻她时，她就会说，你知道吗，我真的很想和汉普顿约会。他就会问，我该怎么办？下周她想让我去参加这个派对。我该去吗？
I would have nothing to say. I wouldn't know what in the world to say. And so he would say, I don't want advice from you. I want advice from Yakov.
我当时无话可说。我根本不知道该说什么。于是他会说，我不想听你的建议。我想要雅科夫的建议。
Yakov?
雅科夫？
Yakov.
雅科夫。
Yakov was a commando in the Israeli army, which meant that for years, in his job, he was dropped from a helicopter into the Mediterranean. He would swim ashore, usually into Lebanon, break into a building, rescue hostages. That was his job. Adam got to know him one summer at Israeli summer army camp.
雅科夫曾是以色列军队的突击队员，这意味着多年来，他的工作就是从直升机上跳入地中海。他会游上岸，通常是进入黎巴嫩，闯入一栋建筑，营救人质。那就是他的工作。亚当是在一个以色列暑期军训营认识他的。
He was the idealized vision of manhood. I mean, I remember specifically, in the Golan, which is the beautiful mountainous region in the north of Israel, we were hiking. And we were talking about different musicians in America. And my friend said, what do you think of Billy Joel? And Yakov said, he's soft.
他是男人气概的理想化身。我的意思是，我特别记得在戈兰高地——以色列北部美丽的山区——我们当时正在徒步旅行。我们谈到了美国的各种音乐人。我的朋友问，你觉得比利·乔尔怎么样？雅科夫说，他太软弱了。
I mean, up till that second, I really liked Billy Joel. I think I owned every one of his albums. I probably knew all of his songs by heart. And literally, from that second to right now, I can't listen to Billy Joel. Every time I listen to it, I'm like, that is so soft, man. Why is he so soft?
我的意思是，在那一秒之前，我真的很喜欢比利·乔尔。我想我拥有他的每一张专辑。我可能把他的所有歌都背下来了。而从那一秒开始，直到现在，我都没法听比利·乔尔了。每次我听他的歌，我都会想，伙计，这也太软弱了吧。他为什么这么软弱？
Anyway, so Jamie would ask me advice as Yakov. And it would be a switch this fast. He'd say, what should I do? I'd be like, I don't know, man. And then he'd say, well, I want to hear from Yakov. And right away, I would just say, listen, Jung wants a man, and you're playing like a child. So until you show her a man, how will she want you?
总之，杰米会让我以雅科夫的身份提供建议。这种转换非常快。他会问，我该怎么办？我会说，我不知道啊，伙计。然后他会说，嗯，我想听听雅科夫的意见。于是我立刻就会说，听着，琼想要的是一个男人，而你现在的表现像个孩子。所以，除非你向她展示一个男人的样子，否则她怎么会想要你呢？
He would say, listen, this party is coming on Saturday. What you are doing is telling Jung, ask her, am I going with you, or I'm just coming to the party? If she says, you're just coming to the party, you say, listen, Jung, I like you. I want to be with you. So you must be very specific, why are you there and why are you wanting to be there. And then it is very simple. It's a transaction, just a man, a woman, what you want, what she wants, end of story.
他会说，听着，周六有个派对。你现在要做的就是告诉琼，问她，我是要和你一起去，还是只是去参加那个派对？如果她说，你只是去参加派对，那你就说，听着，琼，我喜欢你。我想和你在一起。所以你必须非常明确，你为什么在那儿，为什么想在那儿。然后一切就非常简单了。这是一种交易，男人和女人之间，你想要什么，她想要什么，故事结束。
And I would just become Yakov. These weren't things I could say. They weren't things I knew. I didn't know about being a man or not being a man. I didn't know about what women wanted at that point in my life.
我就会完全变成雅科夫。这些话都不是我能说出来的。它们不是我所知的东西。在那个人生阶段，我根本不懂什么叫男人，什么叫不是男人。我也不懂女人想要什么。
Wait. You are saying that not only would you do his voice, but he was actually giving advice that you, yourself, would be unable to give?
等等。你是说你不仅会模仿他的声音，而且他实际上在提供一些你自己根本无法给出的建议？
Yeah, the kinds of things that Yakov would say, I don't think I knew. I certainly wasn't acting like I knew it.
是的，雅科夫会说的那些话，我想我当时并不知道。我也肯定没有表现出我知道的样子。
But even though Adam would give this advice, even though he would become another person, channel the voice and personality of an Israeli commando for Jamie, even though he did all of that, Jamie still would not take the advice. Which raises the question, what does it take? Who among us, my friend, has not had someone who begged them for advice. And we gave them the advice. And in fact, everyone we knew gave them the same advice, and still they did not act.
但尽管亚当会给出这些建议，尽管他会化身为另一个人，为杰米传达这位以色列突击队员的声音和个性，尽管他做了这一切，杰米还是不听劝。这就提出了一个问题，到底需要什么？我的朋友，我们之中谁没有遇到过那种恳求你给建议的人呢？我们也给了建议。事实上，我们认识的每个人都给了他们同样的建议，但他们依然没有采取行动。
Think of the advice that you have given in your life, my friend. When we give advice we witness the puniness of reason when compared with the vastness of human desire and emotion.
想想你一生中给出的那些建议吧，我的朋友。当我们给出建议时，我们见证了理性的渺小，在人类欲望和情感的浩瀚面前，它是多么微不足道。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, most of it was recorded in front of live audiences in Seattle, Washington, and Aspen, Colorado, thanks to public radio station KUOW in Seattle and to HBO's US Comedy Arts Festival in Aspen.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台联合制作的《这就是美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，大部分是在华盛顿州西雅图和科罗拉多州阿斯彭的现场观众面前录制的，感谢西雅图的公共广播电台KUOW和阿斯彭的HBO美国喜剧艺术节。
Today on our program, advice, stories of people trying to give each other advice and why advice is so rarely taken. Act One, Sleepless in Seattle. Writer Sarah Vowell breaks a number of deeply held personal beliefs, and does something she generally tries to avoid. She asks other people for advice, in this case about insomnia. Act Two, Advise and Consent. Some thoughts on why people hardly ever take each other's advice. And Seattle's own Dan Savage has advice for everyone that may save lives. We hope it does. Act Three, Guided Meditation. Cheryl Trykv helps us all unlock the sap that is contained in our inner tree. Also throughout this hour, music from the Black Cat Orchestra, who are with us on stage in Seattle. Stay with us.
今天我们的节目主题是“建议”，讲述人们试图给彼此建议的故事，以及为什么建议往往不被采纳。第一幕，“西雅图不眠夜”。作家萨拉·沃威尔打破了许多根深蒂固的个人信仰，做了一件她通常尽量避免的事情。她向别人寻求建议，这次是关于失眠的。第二幕，“建议与同意”。关于人们为何很少采纳他人建议的一些思考。西雅图的丹·萨维奇将为每个人提供可能挽救生命的建议。我们希望如此。第三幕，“引导冥想”。谢丽尔·特里夫帮我们所有人释放内心之树中蕴含的汁液。此外，在本期节目中，我们将全程欣赏黑猫管弦乐队带来的音乐，他们今天和我们一起在西雅图的舞台上。请继续收听。
Act One, Sleepless in Seattle. So what happens if you actually take the advice people give you, all of it? Sarah  Vowell recently conducted a personal experiment where she did exactly that. She is the author of the book Radio On and a contributing editor to our program.
第一幕，“西雅图不眠夜”。如果你真的采纳了别人给你的所有建议，会发生什么？萨拉·沃威尔最近进行了一项个人实验，她正是这样做的。她是《电台开启》一书的作者，也是我们节目的特约编辑。
I'm holding a baby picture in my hand, the portrait kind from Sears. It's me and my twin sister, Amy. And we're maybe three, dressed alike. She's crying. Amy is this flashing light, blond hair, blue eyes, white tears. And I have one distinguishing characteristic that makes me different from any baby in any picture I've ever seen, dark circles under my eyes. As if I was holding down the swing shift at the tire factory in addition to my official duties as a baby.
我手里拿着一张婴儿照，是西尔斯百货那种肖像照。那是我和我的双胞胎妹妹艾米。我们大约三岁，穿着一样的衣服。她在哭。艾米就像一道闪光，金发、蓝眼、白色的泪珠。而我有一个让我区别于我见过照片中任何婴儿的显著特征：我眼下的黑眼圈。好像我除了作为婴儿的职责外，还在轮胎厂上了夜班一样。
My mother says that when I was small, she'd wake up in the middle of the night and find me calmly playing with my toys. Once when I was 18 months old, she got up to check on me and panicked when she saw the front door swinging open. She found me outside, crawling around the pasture, giggling.
我母亲说，我小时候，她会在半夜醒来，发现我正冷静地玩着玩具。有一次我18个月大时，她起来查看我，看到前门敞开着，惊慌失措。结果发现我在外面，正爬在牧场上咯咯地笑。
I continued to sneak out as a sleepless teenager. Most nights I would go for a walk around 3:00 AM, which was lovely and starlit and safe in Bozeman, Montana. Now I live in Chicago, a city which proudly just edged out New York's murder rate. Don't call us the Second City. So the 3:00 AM joy walks aren't an option anymore. Not that I mind being up at all hours. It's the exhaustion that gets to me. And so recently, I decided enough.
作为一个失眠的青少年，我继续偷溜出去。大多数夜晚，我会在凌晨3点左右去散步，在蒙大拿州博兹曼那样的夜晚既美妙又星光灿烂，而且安全。现在我住在芝加哥，这座城市的谋杀率刚刚骄傲地超过了纽约。别叫我们“第二城市”。所以凌晨3点的快乐散步不再是选项了。并不是我不介意整夜不睡。是那份疲惫让我受不了。所以最近，我决定受够了。
I'm not the advice seeking, therapy going, professional help getting kind, working under the theory that I know my problems and I am unwilling to change. But to overthrow insomnia, I'd break my personal declarations of independence and ask for help. I'd give it five days, I thought, a work week. I am can do when a job is involved.
我不是那种会去寻求建议、接受治疗、寻求专业帮助的人，我坚持认为我了解自己的问题，并且不愿意改变。但为了推翻失眠，我决定打破我的“个人独立宣言”，寻求帮助。我想给自己五天时间，一个工作周。只要有任务，我就能做到。
Day one, Mom. The last time I took advice from my mother I was in high school. She forced me to take a typing class, arguing it might come in handy in later life. And I've never quite forgiven her for being right. But she's a bit an insomniac herself. I called her up, and asked for suggestions on how to handle it.
第一天，妈妈。上一次听从我母亲的建议还是在高中时。她强迫我参加打字课，理由是以后可能派得上用场。我对她是对的这件事至今耿耿于怀。但她自己也有点失眠。我打电话给她，询问如何应对。
As I have gotten older, I've learned to drink my herbal tea.
随着年龄增长，我学会了喝花草茶。
So far so good. Herbal tea, sensible, basic, the boiling of water, Maybe this advice thing isn't as scary as I thought. But Mom's just getting warmed up.
目前还不错。花草茶，合理，基本，烧开水。也许这个建议什么的并不像我想象的那么可怕。但妈妈才刚刚热身。
First of all, first of all, do some real serious soul searching.
首先，首先，做些真正严肃的灵魂搜索。
Oh, god.
哦，天哪。
I have a policy about that word, soul. It is strictly prohibited, except in cases of conversations having to do with okra recipes and Marvin Gaye. My mom doesn't observe these simple, common sense restrictions.
关于“灵魂”这个词，我有一条原则。它被严格禁止，除了在讨论秋葵食谱和马文·盖伊的对话中。我妈妈不遵守这些简单、常识性的限制。
You're supposed to get rid of anything that might be bothering you. I'm talking about things that you need to let go of, things that, in the past, that maybe have upset you or hurt you, that you're still hanging on to. You know what I'm saying?
你应该摆脱任何可能困扰你的事情。我说的是你需要放下的事情，过去可能伤害你或让你痛苦的事情，而你还在耿耿于怀。你知道我在说什么吗？
No, you mean in the new-agey sense, like emotional problems?
不，你是说那种新时代的感悟，比如情感问题？
No, Sarah, I don't think you have an emotional problem.
不，萨拉，我不认为你有情感问题。
Translation, yes, Sarah, I do think you have an emotional problem. Normally, any soul searching on my part is purely accidental. And it's always brought on by a liquid other than herbal tea. So I brew some chamomile, telling myself that, in the right light, it looks a lot like Scotch. I sip three cups and search my soul for deep thoughts. I got nothing.
翻译：是的，萨拉，我确实认为你有情感问题。通常情况下，我的灵魂搜索纯属偶然。而且总是由花草茶以外的液体引发的。所以我泡了一些洋甘菊茶，告诉自己，在合适的灯光下，它看起来很像苏格兰威士忌。我喝了三杯，并在灵魂中搜索深奥的想法。什么也没搜到。
So I try something else. I put on a Billie Holiday song called "Why Was I Born?" Two minutes and 48 seconds later, I realize that perhaps I'm confusing introspection with depression. Soul searching, how do you even know if you're doing it right? I mean, how searched is searched?
所以我尝试了别的东西。我播放了比莉·哈乐黛的一首歌《我为何出生？》。两分48秒后，我意识到也许我把内省和抑郁弄混了。灵魂搜索，你怎么知道你是否做得对呢？我的意思是，搜到什么程度才算搜过？
I try another approach. John Ehrlichman's obituary was just in the paper. And I decide to take a personal inventory by comparing my soul with his. Guess what? I come out on top. Now do the math with me. The occasional late payment on my college loans, Watergate. Periodic participation in obnoxious public radio pledge drives, secret bombing of Cambodia. I can't sleep, he can't breathe.
我尝试了另一种方法。约翰·埃利希曼的讣告刚刚见报。我决定通过对比我的灵魂和他的灵魂来进行个人盘点。猜猜怎么着？我赢了。现在和我算算账。我偶尔迟缴大学贷款，水门事件。偶尔参加讨厌的公共广播募捐活动，秘密轰炸柬埔寨。我睡不着，他喘不上气。
And I fall into sleep immediately, and drift off into the sleep of the just. But the depressing thing is, I wake up four hours later and never get back to bed. So I cross soul searching and herbal tea off the list. Sorry, Mom.
我很快入睡了，进入了正义之士的梦乡。但最令人沮丧的是，四个小时后我就醒了，再也无法入睡。所以我把灵魂搜索和花草茶从清单上划掉了。抱歉，妈妈。
Day two, the doctor. I seek professional help from a doctor at the University of Chicago's sleep disorder lab, one Wallace Mendelson, professor of psychiatry and medicine.
第二天，医生。我向芝加哥大学睡眠障碍实验室的一位医生寻求专业帮助，那是华莱士·门德尔松，精神病学和医学教授。
Well, there's, depending on exactly how you divide things up, 30 or 40 different basic kinds of illnesses of sleep. Among the many causes of insomnia is a condition that's sometimes called psychophysiological or conditioned insomnia.
嗯，根据你划分的方式，大约有30到40种基本的睡眠疾病。失眠的众多原因之一是一种有时被称为精神生理性或条件性失眠的情况。
I don't know if he is a good doctor. But I can tell you this. If his patients want him to help them get to sleep, all they have to do is sit him down with a tape recorder, and ask him to say a few words about his job.
我不知道他是不是个好医生。但我可以告诉你这个：如果他的病人想让他帮忙入睡，他们所要做的就是让他坐在录音机前，请他谈谈他的工作。
Anyway, though he refuses to give me any personal advice, arguing that I'm not his patient, I do manage to squeeze a few pointers out of him for someone, maybe one of those psychophysio-whatchamacallits.
总之，虽然他拒绝给我任何个人建议，理由是我不是他的病人，但我确实设法从他那里挤出了一些针对某些人的提示，也许就是那些“精神生理”什么的。
For that particular subgroup of people, one of the things that can be helpful is to try to strip the bed and the bedroom of any associations, except for sleeping and loving.
对于那一类特定的群体，有用的方法之一是尝试剥离床和卧室的所有联想，除了睡觉和亲密行为。
Loving? Somehow he makes that word sound so dirty. But that night, I take Dr. Mendelson's advice and clear everything out of my bedroom, half of which contains my bed, the other half of which just so happens to function as my office.
亲密行为？不知怎的，他说这个词时听起来很肮脏。但那天晚上，我采纳了门德尔松医生的建议，清理了卧室里的一切。卧室的一半放着我的床，另一半恰好兼作我的办公室。
And I'll be precise now, because this is science. I remove 78 books, stacking them in front of the closet in the other room. I transport 15 pens, a turntable, a transistor radio, a tape recorder, and 23 magazines. I take away dozens of scraps of paper, some of which were handily stored on and in the bed, itself. I unplug the computer and the fax machine, and lug them out. And clearing away all this dusty stuff takes two Kleenex filled hours.
我现在要精确描述，因为这是科学。我清除了78本书，把它们堆在另一个房间的衣柜前。我搬走了15支笔、一台唱机、一台晶体管收音机、一台录音机和23本杂志。我移走了几十张纸屑，其中一些甚至方便地存放在床上和床里。我拔掉电脑和传真机的插头，把它们搬了出去。清理这些尘土飞扬的东西花了我两个装满纸巾的疲惫小时。
Then I get into bed-- in the nude, because the stacks of books are blocking the closet where I keep my pajamas-- and I think about what a mess the living room is, and how I'm going to have to haul all that crap back in here tomorrow. And I never get more than about 30 minutes straight of sleep, though somewhere in there I managed to have a dream in which my bedroom is empty because I got robbed.
然后我躺进被窝——赤身裸体，因为堆满的书挡住了我放睡衣的衣柜——我开始担心客厅有多乱，明天还得把那些破烂都搬回来。我从来没有连续睡超过30分钟，虽然在这期间我做了一个梦，梦见我的卧室被洗劫一空，变得空荡荡的。
Day three, the internet. Doctors and mothers and friends, so old-fashioned, so 20th century. If I want an insomnia-free future, I must look to the future, to the World Wide Web. It promises so much. I do a search on insomnia. The first thing I find is sponsored by the National Institutes of Health. It posits the three main causes of insomnia are old age, depression, and female gender. Well, no wonder I can't solve my little problem.
第三天，互联网。医生、母亲和朋友，太老派了，太20世纪了。如果我想要一个没有失眠的未来，我就必须展望未来，展望万维网。它承诺了太多。我搜索了“失眠”。我找到的第一条是美国国立卫生研究院赞助的。它认为失眠的三个主要原因是：高龄、抑郁和女性性别。好吧，难怪我解决不了我的小问题。
Then I log on to something called the Virtual Hospital at www.vh.org. In the insomnia advice section, one of its suggestions is, don't engage in stimulating activity before bed. Examples include playing a competitive game of cards or watching an exciting program on television.
然后我登录了一个叫“虚拟医院”的网站www.vh.org。在失眠建议部分，它的建议之一是：睡前不要进行刺激性的活动。例子包括玩激烈的纸牌游戏或看电视上令人兴奋的节目。
I decide to take this advice and avoid exciting programs on television. Which means one thing, turn on the Tonight Show. Jay Leno's monologue features innovative humor about airlines and Viagra and Linda Tripp. A hilarious skit called "Presidential Jeopardy" pits Abe Lincoln and George Washington against president Clinton, who scores big in the Hooters waitresses category. Then one of those animal guys comes out with a tiger. The conversation goes like this. Jay Leno, these must be pretty endangered. Animal Guy, yeah, they are.
我决定采纳这条建议，避免电视上的刺激节目。这意味着一件事：打开《今夜秀》。杰·雷诺的独白包含关于航空公司、伟哥和琳达·特里普的创新幽默。一个搞笑的小品叫《总统冒险》，让亚伯拉罕·林肯和乔治·华盛顿与克林顿总统竞争，后者在“Hooters餐厅女招待”类别中得分很高。然后一个动物专家带了一只老虎出来。对话是这样的。杰·雷诺：这些一定是濒危动物吧？动物专家：是的，确实是。
I am asleep before the musical guest comes out. This advice is working the best so far. I stay asleep for five whole hours. Does everyone know about this, that maybe this is the reason Leno's ratings are better than Letterman's?
音乐嘉宾出场前我就睡着了。这是目前为止最有效的建议。我整整睡了五个小时。大家都知道这一点吗？也许这就是为什么雷诺的收视率比莱特曼高的原因？
Day four. A day without caffeine is like-- I'm sure I could come up with a good analogy, but I'm just too tired. Consensus, or should I say, conspiracy? Every last one of my sources-- my mom, my friend, the doctor, the web-- advises against caffeine, which is a problem in that I have been addicted to coffee since I was 15. I no longer drink nearly as much as I used to. But still, my motto, sine coffea nihil sum, without coffee, I'm nothing.
第四天。没有咖啡因的一天就像——我确信我可以想出一个好的类比，但我实在太累了。共识，或者我应该说，阴谋？我所有的消息来源——我妈妈、朋友、医生、网络——都建议不要摄入咖啡因，这对我来说是个问题，因为我从15岁起就对咖啡上瘾。我喝得不再像以前那么多了，但我的座右铭依然是：没咖啡我就什么都不是。
So today I'm planning on nothing. I go cold turkey, starting with a brisk pot of peppermint tea at 8:30. By 10:15, I'm splayed on the couch with a cardigan sweater wrapped around my eyes.
所以今天我打算什么都不做。我采取戒断法，从早上8点半的一壶薄荷茶开始。到10点15分，我瘫倒在沙发上，用一件羊毛衫蒙住双眼。
My head throbs. And the phone rings every 15 minutes. One of the calls is from a telemarketer, who somehow makes me cry.
我的头在剧痛。电话每15分钟响一次。其中一个电话是推销员打来的，他居然把我弄哭了。
At 12:38, I crawl over to the cabinet where I keep the coffee can and sniff its contents. It is a very long day. And guess what? It doesn't work. Thank god. What if I had to do this again? I'm up all night watching the clock, waiting for morning, when I can make coffee. At 5:00 AM, I tell myself, close enough, and suck down six cups before 5:15.
12点38分，我爬到放咖啡罐的柜子边，闻了闻里面的内容。这真是漫长的一天。猜猜怎么着？没用。感谢上帝。如果我还要再做一次怎么办？我整夜躺着看钟，等着早晨，那时我就可以泡咖啡了。凌晨5点，我告诉自己，差不多了，在5点15分之前我猛灌了六杯咖啡。
Now that reason is restored, I come to this conclusion. If there is anything worse than insomnia, it's taking advice about insomnia. Being up in the middle of the night is kind of nice, actually. It's quiet and dark, and the phone doesn't ring. You can listen to records and weirder movies are on TV. I've never known another life, and now I'm not so sure I want to.
现在理性恢复了，我得出这个结论：如果有什么比失眠更糟糕的，那就是听取关于失眠的建议。半夜醒着其实挺好的。安静而黑暗，电话也不会响。你可以听唱片，电视上还会播放更奇怪的电影。我从未体验过另一种生活，现在我不确定自己是否想要。
One of my earliest memories is listening to my dad in the middle of the night. He'd be opening and closing kitchen cabinets, stirring bicarbonate of soda into a glass. I was awake. He was awake. And he seeing no need to fix it. In the middle of the night, lying in bed, he invents these machines I don't pretend to understand.
我最早的记忆之一是半夜听我爸爸的声音。他会打开又关上厨房柜子，把小苏打搅拌进杯子里。我醒着，他醒着，他觉得没必要去解决它。半夜躺在床上，他发明了这些我假装看不懂的机器。
I'm kind of working on a spoke-duplicating lathe. It's really cool. I drew a picture this morning when I woke up. You just feel sorry for those people that slept all night and didn't accomplish anything.
我正在设计一种仿形车床。真的很酷。我今天早上醒来时画了一张图。你只会为那些睡了一整晚却一事无成的人感到惋惜。
We are flawed creatures, all of us. Some of us think that means we should fix our flaws. But get rid of my flaws, and there would be no one left. If I looked in the mirror someday and saw no dark circles under my eyes, I'd probably look better. I just wouldn't look like me. Thank you.
我们都是有缺陷的生物。有些人认为这意味着我们应该修正我们的缺陷。但如果摆脱了我的缺陷，那我就不再是我了。如果有一天我照镜子，发现眼下没有黑眼圈，我可能会看起来更好看。但我看起来就不像我了。谢谢。
Sarah Vowell. Coming up, breezy advice pretending to be serious, serious advice pretending to be breezy. Will you be able to tell the difference? That is in a minute, from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
萨拉·沃威尔。接下来，假装严肃的轻松建议，假装轻松的严肃建议。你能分辨出区别吗？请稍候，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, and invite a variety of writers and performers and reporters to tackle that theme. Today's program, Advice. A show recorded in front of live audiences in Aspen and Seattle. We have arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, Advise and Consent. Let's go to the tape.
这里是《这就是美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周节目中，我们当然都会选择一个主题，并邀请各种作家、表演者和记者来探讨这个主题。今天的节目主题是“建议”。一场在阿斯彭和西雅图的现场观众面前录制的演出。我们现在进入节目的第二幕。第二幕，“建议与同意”。我们来看录音。
There are the times that people give each other advice, and then there are the times that people actually take advice. And they are very different times. And so let us now sort out one from the other. Let us create a taxonomy. Let us name the different species of advice, so we do not confuse ourselves as we go forward from this day.
人们给彼此建议的时候是一回事，人们真正采纳建议的时候又是另一回事。而且这是两个截然不同的时刻。所以让我们把它们区分开来。让我们建立一个分类法。让我们为不同种类的建议命名，这样我们在前进的路上就不会混淆自己。
For help with this, I turned to someone who is an expert on advice, someone who has devoted her entire life to solving other people's problems, my mother. That's the cheapest joke I have ever made in public. Suddenly I'm like Shecky Greene up here.
为了完成这项工作，我求助于一位建议方面的专家，一位将一生都致力于解决他人问题的人：我的母亲。这是我公开讲过的最廉价的笑话了。突然间，我觉得自己成了谢基·格林。
My mom is actually a clinical psychologist, publishes original research, is quoted in newspapers and magazines, until recently, did the advice column for America Online. And she tells this story.
我妈妈实际上是一位临床心理学家，发表过原创研究，在报纸和杂志上被引用，直到最近，她还在美国在线担任建议专栏作家。她讲了这样一个故事。
Well, I had a patient that loved Susan Forward when she was big on the radio.
嗯，我曾有一位病人，她很喜欢苏珊·福沃德（电台心理医生），那时候她在电台上很火。
This is a radio therapist.
这是一个电台治疗师。
Right. And this patient was just making a mess out of her life, just doing everything that was not in her interest. So I said, well, let's do a role reversal. I'll be you and you be Susan Forward. And so I presented the problem from the patient's point of view. And the patient, as Susan Forward, could tell me exactly what she should be doing.
对。那位病人把自己的生活搞得一团糟，做的一切都不利于自己。所以我说，好吧，我们来玩个角色互换。我来演你，你来演苏珊·福沃德。我以病人的角度提出了问题。而作为“苏珊·福沃德”的病人，能够准确地告诉我她应该怎么做。
And then the lights go on. And then she says, well, I know what I should do. But obviously, I'm having trouble doing it, which is at the core.
然后灯亮了。她说，嗯，我知道我该做什么。但显然，我在执行上遇到了困难，这才是核心所在。
People have trouble taking advice. The whole process of therapy is the long process of getting people to the point where they can actually take the advice that any reasonable person would give them.
人们很难采纳建议。整个心理治疗过程是一个漫长的过程，目的是让人们达到能够真正听从任何理智的人都会给他们的建议的程度。
There's one thing that is very interesting about giving advice. And there's been some research to support this, that people who give advice feel terrific afterwards, and the people who receive the advice, particularly when it's unsolicited, feel terrible. So what we've learned from this research is that advice is really terrific for the advice giver. And it's not so good for the advice receiver.
关于给出建议，有一点非常有趣。已经有一些研究支持这一点：给出建议的人事后会感觉极好，而接受建议的人，尤其是在未被要求的情况下，会感觉极差。所以我们从这些研究中了解到，建议对给出建议的人来说真的很棒，但对接受建议的人来说就不那么好了。
Either way, giving them the right advice has nothing to do with whether or not they will take the advice. This is garden variety advice.
无论如何，给他们正确的建议与他们是否会采纳建议毫无关系。这只是普通大众的建议。
Then there's the advice provided by our nation's burgeoning advice industry, which includes therapists, self help books, advice columns in newspapers. And so in preparation for today's show, I talked to Dan Savage, who has been an advice columnist for eight years in The Stranger, here in Seattle and around the country. And he is going to be out here in person in a few minutes. But when we talked on tape a few weeks ago, he expressed this cheerful view of his chosen profession.
还有我们国家新兴的建议产业提供的建议，包括治疗师、自助书籍、报纸建议专栏。为了准备今天的节目，我和丹·萨维奇谈了谈，他在西雅图及全国各地的《陌生人》报刊上做了八年的建议专栏作家。几分钟后他会亲自到场。但几周前我们录音交谈时，他表达了对他所从事职业的这种愉快的看法。
Dan, when you write the column, do you think people take the advice?
丹，当你写这个专栏时，你认为人们会采纳建议吗？
Not usually. No. But most of the time, I don't think people take advice from anybody. People seek advice to sort of suss out all the possibilities, all their possible choices, and then very often just do what they would have done to begin with, without asking anyone for advice. So no, I think most of the time people don't take my advice. They don't take anyone's advice.
通常不会。不。但大多数时候，我不认为人们会听取任何人的建议。人们寻求建议是为了梳理所有的可能性，所有的选择，然后往往还是按照他们最初不询问任何人时就会做的那样去做。所以不，我认为大多数时候人们不采纳我的建议。他们不采纳任何人的建议。
Well, if people don't take advice, then why put yourself in a job where you're giving advice for a living?
那么，如果人们不采纳建议，为什么还要从事这种以提供建议为生的工作呢？
Because it pays well.
因为报酬丰厚。
Advice columns, Dan says, are not, not, not about giving advice.
丹说，建议专栏不是、不是、不是关于提供建议的。
And when you think about it, one person sent in a question. But the column is being read by millions of other people who didn't ask the question, who aren't in that situation, who don't have that problem. Why are those millions of other people reading? Schadenfreude or they're reading for pleasure. They're reading because other people's problems are entertaining. They are reading to be titillated. And if you write a good advice column, you do do all those things.
当你仔细想想，一个人寄来一个问题。但这个专栏被数百万没有提出问题、没有处于那种处境、没有那种麻烦的人阅读。为什么那数百万其他人要读？幸灾乐祸，或者纯粹是为了消遣。他们读是因为别人的问题很有趣。他们读是为了寻求刺激。如果你写了一个好的建议专栏，你确实做了所有这些事情。
So in one way, it's not a racket, if you focus on what an advice column actually does, which is not give advice.
所以从某种意义上说，如果你专注于建议专栏真正做的事情——也就是不提供建议，那它就不是什么骗局。
Dan, I have to say, was unrelenting on this point. I asked him, is he happy when he comes up with some right, good advice for somebody? No. He's happy when he thinks of something funny to say in the column.
我必须说，丹在这个问题上毫不妥协。我问他，当他为某人想出一个正确的好建议时，他会高兴吗？不。他只有在专栏里想到什么有趣的话可说时才高兴。
OK. Why does he quote actual experts in the column if he's not trying to give people actual advice? His answer, to give the column the appearance of an advice column.
好吧。既然他不是在试图给人们实际建议，那他为什么在专栏里引用真正的专家的意见？他的回答是：为了给专栏披上“建议专栏”的外衣。
I pretend to write an advice column, is how I feel about it. And there are times when I'm pretending to write my advice column where it sounds a lot like an advice column.
这就是我的感受：我是在假装写建议专栏。有时候当我假装写建议专栏时，它听起来确实很像一个建议专栏。
He also told me this one incredible thing about the advice column business, about the letters that people send in asking for advice.
他还告诉了我一件关于建议专栏行业的令人难以置信的事，关于人们寄来寻求建议的信件。
When you write an advice column, one of the secrets of the genre is the letter will include the advice that, ultimately, you give. The letter will say, here's my problem. And I don't know what to do. This is what I think I should do. Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. And so you have to cut that paragraph. Otherwise, you're just going to repeat it.
当你写建议专栏时，这类文体的秘密之一就是信件本身就会包含你最终给出的建议。信件会说：这是我的问题，我不知道该怎么办。这是我认为我应该做的，巴拉巴拉巴拉。所以你必须删掉那一段。否则，你只是在重复它而已。
Because very often, the person knows exactly what they have to do. They do have to leave their husband, or they do have to turn their kid in to the cops, or they do have to get their nipples pierced, or whatever.
因为很多时候，当事人非常清楚他们必须做什么。他们确实必须离开丈夫，或者确实必须把孩子交给警察，或者确实必须穿乳钉，或者诸如此类。
And how often does that happen, that they actually include the answer in their letter?
那么这种情况发生的频率有多高？他们真的在信里包含了答案？
Like 25% of the time.
大约25%的时候。
But there's another category of advice to include in our little taxonomy. In the last year, on two different occasions, I've turned to my father to ask for advice. And these are two of the first times that I have actually turned to him for direct advice, really, since I was a kid.
但在我们的小分类法中还有另一类建议。在过去的一年里，我曾两次向父亲寻求建议。这确实是我自童年以来第一次真正向他寻求直接的建议。
So the first of these times, I asked for advice about whether or not to buy or lease a car. And the second time, I needed advice on setting up a 401(k). And my dad is this business guy. He is an accountant. He gives people advice like this all day long. And each time, he sat at his desk in his office. And he asked me some questions. And he ran some numbers. And then he told me what to do. And I did it.
第一次是关于买车还是租车的问题。第二次是我需要关于设立401(k)养老金计划的建议。我爸爸是个生意人。他是一位会计师。他整天都在给别人提供这样的建议。每一次，他都坐在办公室的桌前。他问了我一些问题。他算了一些数字。然后他告诉我该怎么做。我就照做了。
And each time there was this very real intimacy to it. They were intimate conversations. There is a real intimacy to real advice, when it actually happens. There is something about putting your fate in someone else's hands, and saying, I need help. I need your help. Help me. Help me. Here I am. I need you.
每一次都有一种非常真实的亲密感。那是亲密的对话。当真正的建议发生时，它确实有一种真实的力量。当你把自己的命运交到别人手中，说“我需要帮助。我需要你的帮助。帮帮我。帮帮我。我在这里。我需要你”，这其中有些东西（很动人）。
And you were going to him for advice about this thing that didn't have anything to do with emotional life, yours or his. Yet it affected your emotional life in a real way.
你找他寻求关于这件事的建议，而这件事与情感生活无关，无论对他还是对你。然而它确实以一种真实的方式影响了你的情感生活。
Yeah.
是的。
And that's what is moving about it, actually. And it's very male, I think, very hetero male, that you were able to have an emotional bond with your father, but you had to have this sort of MacGuffin to bond over that had nothing to do with feelings, just numbers.
这就是动人的地方。而且我认为这非常“男性”，非常异性恋男性的特征：你能够与父亲建立情感联系，但你必须通过某种“麦高芬”（推动情节的事物）来建立连接，这与感情无关，只是数字。
Yeah, but I think it points to the power of what advice is. I mean, it kind of doesn't matter what it is about. It could be about anything.
是的，但我认为这指出了建议的力量。我的意思是，它到底关于什么并不重要。它可以关于任何事。
That's true.
没错。
See, but this whole idea of the intimacy of giving advice, like in a personal setting, that you would actually turn to somebody and say, I don't know what to do. Help me out. The intimacy of that is so powerful, that I feel like, in a way, the difference between that act and what happens in an advice column is the same thing as the difference between, you know, having sex with somebody in private and what happens in a porno film.
看，这种在私人场合提供建议的亲密感，你真的会转向某人说：我不知道该怎么办。帮帮我。这种亲密感是如此强大，以至于我觉得从某种程度上说，那个行为与建议专栏里发生的事情之间的区别，就像在私下里与人发生性关系和在色情电影中发生的事情之间的区别一样。
I think that's absolutely true. An advice column is a public performance of a private act. And just as appearing in pornos betrays something about the person appearing in it-- if you're the kind of person who appears in pornos, it tells people things about you, good and bad. I think also being the kind of person who seeks advice out in a public format tells the listener or the reader something about you, good or bad. I certainly think when I've heard Dr. Laura's show, I think who are these idiots who would call this woman?
我认为这绝对是真的。建议专栏是私下行为的公开表演。正如出演色情片会背叛出演者的一些特质——如果你是那种出演色情片的人，它会告诉别人关于你的事情，好的和坏的。我也认为，如果是那种在公共场合寻求建议的人，也会让听众或读者看出关于你的一些事情，无论好坏。我当然认为当我听到劳拉博士的节目时，我会想：这些会打电话给这个女人的白痴到底是谁？
Well, now to give advice to all of us in a public forum, whatever it is that makes us, author of the advice column "Savage Love" and the book made for those columns, please welcome Dan Savage.
现在，要在公共论坛上给我们所有人提供建议，无论它是什么，请欢迎《萨维奇之爱》建议专栏的作者，以及那本为那些专栏而写的书的作者，丹·萨维奇。
Usually it goes like this. You're watching some drunk in a bar scream at his date. His face is red. He's standing, she's sitting, it's ugly. And you look. You can't help it. And suddenly, he sees you seeing him. And then he asks, what are you looking at?
通常是这样的。你看到酒吧里有个醉鬼在对他约会的女伴大喊大叫。他的脸涨红了。他站着，她坐着，场面很难看。而你正在看。你忍不住。突然，他看到你在看他。然后他问：你在看什么？
You can be from another country. You can be a very young child. And still, the first time you're asked this question, you know it's a trick question. What are you looking at? It's a baboon thing to do, really, a way for an insecure monkey to reassure himself that he's the alpha male. He's challenging you, smaller and weaker monkey, to see if you have the guts to tell him, bigger and drunker monkey, the truth.
你可能来自另一个国家。你可能是一个很小的孩子。但第一次被问到这个问题时，你还是知道这是一个陷阱题。“你在看什么？”这实际上是一种狒狒的行为，一个缺乏安全感的猴子确认自己是雄性阿尔法的手段。他在挑战你——更小更弱的猴子——看看你是否有胆量告诉他——更大更醉的猴子——真相。
You're looking at a jerk. Deep down, he knows he's a jerk. And now he knows you know. He was attracting attention to himself acting like a jerk. That's what you were looking at.
你在看一个混蛋。在内心深处，他知道自己是个混蛋。现在他知道你也知道了。他是通过表现得像个混蛋来吸引对他自己的关注。这就是你在看的东西。
"What are you looking at" can have an added element of terror at times for gay men, because sometimes we look at guys who aren't acting like baboons. Sometimes we just look. And sometimes a guy, who might not want to be looked at, will catch us looking. In these circumstances, what are you looking at usually equals I saw what you were looking at, faggot.
“你在看什么”对男同性恋来说有时会增加一层恐怖，因为有时我们看的男人并不是在表现得像狒狒。有时我们只是看看。有时一个不想被看的男人会撞见我们在看他。在这种情况下，“你在看什么”通常等于“我看到了你在看什么，基佬”。
Instead of him knowing you know he's a jerk. You know he knows you're a fag. And you blame yourself, of course, vestigial shame. You got sloppy checking out some straight guy's butt, and you got caught. It's not even the looking so much that gives us away, but the nervousness, this fear of getting caught, that makes our looks different and distinguishable from the looks that straight men give each other.
而不是他知道你知道他是个混蛋。现在是他知道你知道他是个基佬。当然，你会自责，这是遗留的羞耻感。你刚才在偷看某个直男的屁股时太大意了，结果被抓住了。其实暴露我们的不仅仅是看，而是那种紧张感，那种被抓包的恐惧，让我们的眼神变得不同，并与直男互看的眼神区别开来。
Of course, not all straight men mind being looked at by gay men. Some find our attentions flattering, hipsters, porn stars, public radio personalities.
当然，并不是所有的直男都介意被男同性恋看。有些人发现我们的关注令人受宠若惊，比如潮人、色情明星、公共广播电台的个性人物。
But violence so often follows this kind of "what are you looking at" that even when it doesn't, you still get the adrenaline shock and the adrenaline hangover and the adrenaline flashbacks. It's like a conditioned response. I expect that Matthew Shepard was asked what he was looking at by the two straight guys that beat him to death.
但暴力往往紧随这种“你在看什么”之后，即使没有发生，你仍然会受到肾上腺素的冲击、肾上腺素的宿醉和肾上腺素的闪回。这就像一种条件反射。我猜马修·谢巴德当时就被那两个把他打死的直男问过“你在看什么”。
Now in some places you can safely assume all the men are gay. Health clubs, Manhattan, Ikea. You can look just as much and just as obviously as you like. But in most places, self preservation requires you to assume that all the guys are straight. High school, Wyoming, Sears. If you're going to check the guys out at Sears, you need to look straight yourself. And you need to look like you ain't looking.
在某些地方，你可以安全地假设所有的男人都是同性恋。健身俱乐部、曼哈顿、宜家。你可以想看多久、多明显都行。但在大多数地方，自我保护要求你假设所有的男人都是直男。高中、怀俄明州、西尔斯百货。如果你打算在西尔斯百货打量男人，你得让自己看起来很直。而且你得看起来不像是在看。
One of the ways gay men spot each other in straight land is by waiting for the glance, the look that looks without looking. If a straight guy at Sears wants to look at you, he'll just turn and face you. No nerves, no sidelong glances. He just looks.
男同性恋在直男领域发现彼此的方法之一，是等待那一眼，那种“看着又不看”的眼神。如果西尔斯百货的一个直男想看你，他会直接转过脸对着你。没有紧张，没有侧目。他就是看。
But a gay guy who wants to look at a guy at Sears-- who he thinks might be gay, but isn't sure about since he is at Sears-- he won't turn. He keeps his head straight as he passes. His eyeballs, however, follow you as you walk by, moving into their far corners. But he doesn't turn his head. If you're gay, you do the same. Your eyeballs follow his, but you keep looking straight ahead as you pass.
但一个想看西尔斯百货某个男人的男同性恋——他以为对方可能是同性恋，但又不确定，因为这可是西尔斯——他不会转头。他经过时会保持头直视前方。然而，当对方走过时，他的眼球会跟着转，转到眼角的极点。但他不转头。如果你是同性恋，你也会这样做。你的眼球跟着他转，但你经过时依然直视前方。
Actually, this is a complicated dynamic. And I'd like to demonstrate. Can I have a volunteer from the audience? Bring up the lights for a second. This theater seats about 1,600. And according to the actuarial tables for public radio crowd this size, there should be one straight man.
事实上，这是一个复杂的动态过程。我想演示一下。能有位观众志愿者吗？把灯光调亮一点。这个剧院大约有1600个座位。根据针对这种规模公共广播人群的精算表，这里应该有一个直男。
Did you raise your hand, sir? Now how lucky for us, he is in the front row. Why don't you come right up here? It's you, darling, sweetheart. Come on. The show's--
这位先生，你举手了吗？真幸运，你在前排。你为什么不直接上来呢？就是你，亲爱的。来吧。节目——
OK. We're going to do this look, just you and me. It's going to be very special. What's you're name? This is--
好的。我们要玩这个“眼神游戏”，就你和我。会很特别。你叫什么名字？这是——
Michael.
迈克尔。
Do you pledge to public radio?
你捐赠公共广播吗？
I do now.
我现在捐了。
You do now. Can I have your credit card? We'll just return it after-- go stand right there. Turn around. No, show them your butt, not me your butt. OK.
你现在捐了。能把你的信用卡给我吗？我们一会儿——就站在那儿。转过去。不，给他们看你的屁股，不是给我。好的。
Straight guys are always so quick to show you their ass. It's the great forbidden straight guy zone, that once the opportunity presents itself.
直男总是那么快就把屁股露给你看。那是伟大的禁忌直男区，一旦机会出现的话。
Don't look at me. We're at Sears. We're going to walk past each other. We're both gay. Just pretend. We're walking past each other. Our eyes meet. Right? Our heads don't turn. Our eyes meet, our eyes meet, our eyes meet. When we get past each other, our eyes hurt. Eye strain, eye strain. And then we turn and look.
别看着我。我们在西尔斯。我们要擦肩而过。我们都是同性恋。假装一下。我们经过对方。我们的眼神交汇。对吧？我们不转头。我们的眼神交汇，眼神交汇，眼神交汇。当我们经过对方后，我们的眼睛痛了。眼部压力，眼部压力。然后我们转过身看。
Only after passing each other, do you turn and look. All gay men do this. We do it all the time. If the guy you're walking by doesn't lock eyes and doesn't turn once you've passed him, you know he is not gay. If the guy looks once you have passed him, it means he's gay, but it doesn't necessarily mean that he's interested. He could just be checking to see if you're checking him out. You might be doing the same, checking to see if he is checking you out, when you're not interested, which means that you could both be looking, but neither of you are actually interested.
只有在经过对方后，你才转过身看。所有男同性恋都这么做。我们一直这么做。如果你经过的那个男人没有锁定眼神，并且在你经过后没有转头，你就知道他不是同性恋。如果那个男人在你经过后回头看，那就意味着他是同性恋，但这并不一定意味着他感兴趣。他可能只是在查看你是否在打量他。而你可能也在做同样的事，查看他是否在打量你，而你其实并不感兴趣，这意味着你们可能都在看，但其实都没兴趣。
Now imagine doing this every day whenever you pass a man for the rest of your life, whether you're interested in him or not. Eye strain is basically 80% of the gay lifestyle.
现在想象一下，如果你余生的每一天，只要经过一个男人，无论你对他是否感兴趣，都要做这件事。眼部压力基本上构成了80%的男同性恋生活方式。
Now checking out a guy you're pretty sure is straight is a lot riskier. Some straight men, though, you've got to look at. They're too pretty. Asking for it. It's true.
现在，打量一个你很确定是直男的人风险要大得多。但有些直男，你就是得看。他们太漂亮了。自找的。这是真的。
But I recently discovered something that allows me to check out straight guys without risk, without fear. And it works every time. I offer it here today as a public service. I am an advice columnist, and as my regular readers know, I'm interested in just one thing, helping others. And this is advice that could help save lives. Gay men, carry this thing wherever you go, and guys will assume you're straight always. You could be in a supermarket wearing a dress and clogs, filling your grocery cart with butter flavored Crisco. But if you've got this thing with you, you are straight.
但我最近发现了一件事，让我可以毫无风险、毫无恐惧地打量直男。而且每次都奏效。我今天在这里把它作为一项公共服务提供给大家。我是个建议专栏作家，正如我的老读者所知，我只对一件事感兴趣：帮助他人。这是可能挽救生命的建议。男同性恋们，无论走到哪里都带着这个东西，男人们就会一直以为你是直男。你可以穿着裙子和木屐在超市里，把购物车塞满黄油味的起酥油。但如果你带着这个东西，你就是直男。
I speak, of course, of the human infant. My boyfriend, Terry, will walk out on stage now and strap a baby backpack, filled to the brim with baby, to my back. You'll scare the prop. He can't see you. Sh.
我说的当然是人类婴儿。我的男朋友特里现在会走上台，把一个塞满婴儿的婴儿背带绑在我的背上。你会吓到道具的。他看不见你。嘘。
My boyfriend and I adopted a baby about 11 months ago. This is not our baby. I would not exploit my baby like this. This is an actor. This baby has a SAG card and made more money this year than you did.
我和男朋友在大约11个月前收养了一个婴儿。这不是我们的孩子。我不会这样利用我的孩子。这是一个演员。这个婴儿有工会会员证，今年赚的钱比你多。
Now after we adopted the baby, I don't remember when I realized that the baby, in addition to being the best thing that ever happened to us, the apple of our eyes, also functions as a get out of gay bashing free card. But I realized it soon after we brought him home. And I realized it at the supermarket.
在收养婴儿后，我不记得我是在什么时候意识到，这个婴儿不仅是我们发生过的最好的事，是我们心头的苹果，它还充当了一张“免受恐同攻击”的卡。但在把他带回家后不久我就意识到了。我在超市意识到了这一点。
Picking through the produce with the baby strapped to my back, I paused to check out a guy a little ways down the aisle. He turned, caught me looking, and before I could look away, he smiled. He wasn't gay. He had a girl hanging on him. There was red meat and beer in this cart. And he didn't give me a nervous glance. He just turned and looked.
背着婴儿在超市里挑选农产品时，我停下来打量了一下过道另一头的一个男人。他转过身，撞见我在看他，在我还没来得及移开目光前，他笑了。他不是同性恋。他身边有个女孩。他的购物车里有红肉和啤酒。而且他没有给我那种紧张的眼神。他只是转过头，看着我。
I didn't know what to make of him. He kept smiling at me. Was he bisexual? Beer, red meat, well dressed, no. Not bisexual.
我不知道该怎么看待他。他一直在对我笑。他是双性恋吗？啤酒、红肉、穿着讲究，不。不是双性恋。
Then it hit me. He assumed I was straight too. And he smiled to be polite. He thought we met in straight land somewhere-- at school or at work-- and he couldn't remember where he knew me from. But to be on the safe side, and so as not to offend me, he smiled and nodded. Hey, how are you doing, he said, instead of, what are you looking at? Hey, how ya' doing is never a trick question. It's straight guy--
然后我明白了。他也以为我是直男。他微笑是为了礼貌。他以为我们在“直男领域”的某个地方见过——在学校或工作中——他记不清在哪见过我。但为了稳妥起见，为了不冒犯我，他微笑并点头。他说：“嘿，你好吗？”而不是“你在看什么？”“嘿，你好吗”从来都不是陷阱题。这是直男——
So many people have this impulse to put their hands over my mouth. I don't understand. Small children. Hey, how ya' doing is never a trick question. It's straight guy code for you are one of us.
很多人有一种冲动想捂住我的嘴。我不明白。小孩子。嘿，你好吗，从来都不是陷阱题。这是直男密码，意思是“你是我们的一员”。
The next time I was at the supermarket with the baby, it happened again. I looked, got caught, got smiled at. Pretty soon, I wasn't sneaking peeks anymore. I was checking out straight guys on the street, in airports, in restaurants. So long as I had the baby on my back, I could look at straight guys as boldly as any straight guy would look at a straight guy. I suffer no more eye strain. And it's all, hey, how ya' doing, and never, what are you looking at? I mean, admit it. Don't I look straight? Straighter now than when I first walked on stage?
下一次我在超市带着孩子时，又发生了同样的事。我看了，被抓包，收获了微笑。很快，我不再偷偷摸摸了。我可以理直气壮地打量街头、机场、餐馆里的直男。只要我背着孩子，我就能像任何直男打量直男那样大胆地打量直男。我再也不用受眼部压力之苦了。而且全是“嘿，你好吗”，从来没有“你在看什么”。我的意思是，承认吧。我不看起来很直吗？比起我刚上台时是不是更直了？
I will now put on a pink tutu. Even in a pink tutu, don't I look straight? I quickly progressed from checking out straight guys to flirting with straight guys. It became a game. They assumed I was straight because I had this baby, this monstrous, rotten, awful, stinking baby.
我现在要穿上一件粉红色的芭蕾舞裙。即使穿着粉色芭蕾舞裙，我不看起来也很直吗？我很快就从打量直男进步到勾搭直男。这成了一个游戏。他们以为我是直男，因为我有这个孩子，这个怪异、顽皮、糟糕、恶臭的孩子。
They assumed I was straight because I had this baby with me. OK. How far could I take this? How gay could I act and still be thought straight? Could I ask him what gymnasium he attended? Yes. Could I compliment his shirt? Yes. Could I work the original cast recording of Stephen Sondheim's A Little Night Music into conversation and still be thought straight? Yes.
他们以为我是直男，因为我有这个孩子陪着。好的。我能把这个谎言带到多远？我能表现得有多娘，却依然被认为是直男？我可以问他去哪个健身房吗？可以。可以夸奖他的衬衫吗？可以。可以把史蒂芬·桑德海姆的《小夜曲》原声带带入对话，却依然被认为是直男吗？可以。
Ironically, when I'm with the baby, the only people I get what are you looking at attitude from are other gay men. Sometimes I'll see a cute little fag boy, forget the baby is on my back, give him the walk past, turn, look, look. Like the straight guys at the supermarket, the gay men on the street assume I'm straight. And if they catch me looking, they assume I'm a closet case, and the most contemptible kind, married, kids, out cruising for sex with the baby.
讽刺的是，当我带着孩子时，唯一给我“你在看什么”这种态度的人是其他男同性恋。有时我会看到一个可爱的小基佬，忘了背上背着孩子，对他玩那一套“经过、转头、看”。就像超市里的直男一样，街上的同性恋男人以为我是直男。如果他们撞见我在看，他们以为我是深柜，而且是最令人鄙夷的那种：结婚、生子，还带着孩子出来钓鱼（寻欢）。
But take my advice, guys. You want to pass, get a baby. It works everywhere. We live near a park-- me and my boyfriend, and our useful baby-- and a couple of high school soccer teams practice and play games at the park near our house. But before the baby came, I wouldn't stop and stare. But now, I sit in the stands, baby on my back, and I watch them play. The baby babbles, the sun sets-- the other dads, some of them not too hard on the eyes, themselves-- turn to me. They smile, they nod. I'm one of them. I smile back. Hey, I say, how you doing? Thank you.
但听我的建议，伙计们。如果你想混入人群，带个孩子。它在哪都管用。我们住在公园附近——我和男朋友，还有我们有用的孩子——几支高中足球队在我们家附近的公园练习和比赛。在孩子来之前，我不会停下来盯着看。但现在，我坐在看台上，背着孩子，看着他们踢球。孩子咿呀学语，太阳下山——其他的爸爸们，有些人看起来还不错——转向我。他们微笑，点头。我是他们的一员。我微笑着回应。嘿，我说，你好吗？谢谢。
Dan Savage.
丹·萨维奇。
[MUSIC - "RECORDED LIVE IN SEATTLE" BY BLACK CAT ORCHESTRA]
[音乐 - 黑猫管弦乐队“西雅图现场录音”]
The Black Cat Orchestra. Act Three, Guided Meditation. To send us all out of here with a moment of reflection, a time for us to pause and look inside, and think about some of what we've learned, please welcome writer and performer Cheryl Trykv.
黑猫管弦乐队。第三幕，“引导冥想”。为了让我们在反思中结束这一时刻，让我们停顿并审视内心，思考一下我们学到的一些东西，请欢迎作家和表演者谢丽尔·特里夫。
We all here tonight live on planet Earth. Now that's a fact. And when we move the letter H off the end of that planet Earth, and put it back at the top where it belongs, what have we got? Heart. Now let me ask you this, on the solar map, who are Earth's immediate neighbors? Mars and Venus. What does that tell us? That we've got war on one side, and on the other side love. So you see, we actually want to move away from Mars, not toward it. NASA doesn't seem to see it that way. NASA thinks Mars is the next big thing. But why should it be? Let me tell you something. NASA is run by a bunch of meat-eaters.
我们今晚在这里的人都住在地球（Earth）上。这是事实。当我们把Earth结尾的字母H移走，把它放回到它所属的首位时，我们得到了什么？心脏（Heart）。现在让我问你这个，在太阳系地图上，地球的近邻是谁？火星（Mars）和金星（Venus）。这告诉我们什么？一边是战争，另一边是爱。所以你看，我们其实是想远离火星，而不是走向它。NASA似乎并不这么认为。NASA认为火星是下一个大事。但为什么要这样呢？让我告诉你一件事。NASA是由一群食肉动物运作的。
Tonight, I'd like you to join me in an exercise designed to help us release these terror-torial hostilities created by the meat eaters, and rather embody the virtues of Venus. Blabbidy, blabbidy, blah, blah, blah.
今晚，我希望你们加入我的一个练习，旨在帮助我们释放由食肉动物创造的这种“恐怖主义”敌意，转而体现金星的美德。巴拉巴拉巴拉，巴拉巴拉。
So let's take a deep breath. Fill your lungs. Hold it. And release all the day's negativity. Maybe you couldn't be comped to be here tonight and had to pay full ticket price. Release that resentment. Take another deep breath. Hold it. And release. Maybe you parked illegally outside, and yours is [UNINTELLIGIBLE] they will tow. Don't worry. They will. Release that canker worm of care. Take a final deep breath. Hold it. Maybe you had to share the dressing room with a sex pervert. Mirror hog. And release.
那么，让我们深呼吸。充满肺部。屏住呼吸。释放一天中所有的负面情绪。也许你今晚不想来这里，却不得不支付全额票价。释放那种怨恨。再深呼吸。屏住呼吸。释放。也许你在外面违章停车了，你的车被拖走了。别担心。他们会的。释放那种担忧的毒虫。最后深呼吸。屏住呼吸。也许你不得不和性变态共用更衣室。镜子霸占者。释放。
Now, I'm going to count from one to 8,000. And by the time I reach 7,011, you're going to find yourself in a very deep sleep. Are you ready? One, you are relaxing. Two, becoming more and more relaxed. Three, terribly, terribly relaxed. Four, so relaxed it's uncanny. Five, [MUTTERS] 7,998, terribly, terribly relaxed. 7,999, barely a pulse. 8,000. Good.
现在，我要从1数到8000。当我数到7011时，你们会发现自己进入了深度睡眠。准备好了吗？1，你正在放松。2，变得越来越放松。3，非常、非常放松。4，放松得离奇。5，[嘟囔] 7998，非常、非常放松。7999，几乎没有脉搏。8000。很好。
Now let's navigate the psychic arena that templates every day reality. So let's find ourselves at the sideshow carnival. Conjure the image. That's right. And as we fight our way through the crowd of teen runaways and raving drag queens whacked out on fen-phen, perhaps you'll notice that all the players in the scene are facets of ourselves. And perhaps you'd like to ask yourself, where is that screaming coming from? For an answer, let's move over to the pig man's tent. Conjure the image. See the mystic horror as the pig man wipes his odd little tail with the sleeve of his Burberry shirt. See the pig man's fat little hands, his scrambly fingers. Perhaps his feet are a little like your own.
现在，让我们导航一下那个塑造日常现实的精神舞台。让我们在狂欢嘉年华找到自己。在脑海中构筑图像。没错。当我们穿过那群因为服用“芬芬”减肥药而发疯的青少年逃跑者和狂乱变装皇后的人群时，也许你会注意到场景中的所有角色都是我们自己的不同侧面。也许你想问自己：那种尖叫声是从哪里来的？为了得到答案，让我们移步到“猪人”的帐篷。构筑图像。看看那个神秘的恐怖景象，猪人正用他巴宝莉衬衫的袖子擦拭他那奇怪的小尾巴。看看猪人那肥胖的小手，他那乱抓的手指。也许他的脚有点像你自己的。
Don't look away. Meet your inner guide. Now ask the pig man whatever you'd like, but be prepared, he may reveal something you don't want to hear. Listen carefully. Beneath the squealing gibberish-- that's right-- is a message just for you. [PIG SQUEALING] Eat more fish. More fish, eat it.
别移开目光。去见见你的内在向导。现在问猪人你想问的任何事情，但要做好准备，他可能会揭示一些你不想听到的东西。仔细听。在尖叫的胡言乱语之下——没错——有一个专属于你的信息。[猪尖叫声] 多吃鱼。多吃鱼，吃吧。
As we exit the tent and make our way back to the midway, please stay with the group. Now is not the time to wander off by yourselves. Perhaps you're looking for a private retreat to visit, so you can contemplate the possible, if any, meaning of your personal journey. Fine. We'll all go.
当我们走出帐篷回到大道上时，请留在小组中。现在不是你们独自游荡的时候。也许你在寻找一个私人静修处去访问，这样你就可以思考你的个人旅程可能存在的意义（如果有的话）。很好。我们都去。
Find inside a beautiful, secret garden. Take a moment to conjure the image. Secret garden, that's right. Lush. Feel free to be as detailed as possible. [LAUGHS] Oh, those hydrangea make me laugh. Who put those there?
在内心找到一个美丽的秘密花园。花点时间构筑图像。秘密花园，没错。郁郁葱葱。[笑声] 哦，那些绣球花让我笑了。是谁把它们放在那里的？
Oh, look. A babbling brook. Why, it won't shut up. Our talkative little friend needs to be dammed. See yourself consulting with your own engineers, drawing up plans for your own inner barrier, your own private Hoover Dam. See your own workers walking the scaffold high above voluminous vats of wet concrete. Perhaps you'd like to ask yourself, are my workers union?
哦，看。一条喋喋不休的小溪。天哪，它没完没了。我们这位喋喋不休的小朋友需要被拦住。看着你自己与你自己的工程师商量，为你自己的内在屏障、你自己的私人胡佛大坝起草计划。看着你自己的工人在湿水泥大桶上方高处的脚手架上行走。也许你想问问自己：我的工人是工会的吗？
Now let's just sit for a moment and enjoy all we've created. Gradually, we begin to discover, perhaps to our surprise, what a glorious, all-purpose secret garden this is. But let's just sit, contemplate, give thanks. All right. Let's go. Keep it moving.
现在让我们坐一会儿，享受我们所创造的一切。渐渐地，我们开始发现，也许让我们感到惊讶的是，这是一个多么辉煌、多功能的秘密花园。但让我们坐着，沉思，心怀感激。好了。我们走吧。保持移动。
Now, I'm going to count backwards from 8,000 to one. And when you hear the number one, you will awake. And intuitively, you will want to eat more fish. And our numbers will grow and form a huge block of voting power. Are you ready? 8,000, coming up slowly. 7,999, slowly now. Don't hurt yourselves. 7,998, slowly, I'm not joking. [MUTTERS] Three, two, and one. Thank you.
现在，我要从8000倒数到1。当你听到数字“1”时，你就会醒来。你会直觉地想吃更多的鱼。我们的队伍会壮大，形成一股巨大的投票力量。准备好了吗？8000，慢慢来。7999，慢一点。别伤着自己。7998，慢点，我不是在开玩笑。[嘟囔] 3，2，和1。谢谢。
Ms. Cheryl Trykv.
谢丽尔·特里夫女士。
Well our program was produced today by Alix Spiegel, Julie Snyder, and myself with Nancy Updike. Contributing editors, Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, and Consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Jorge Just, Todd Bachmann, and [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
我们的节目今天由艾丽克斯·斯皮格尔、朱莉·斯奈德和我自己制作，还有南希·厄普代克。特约编辑：保罗·托夫、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林和顾问萨拉·沃威尔。制作协助：豪尔赫·贾斯特、托德·巴赫曼和[听不清]。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our stage crew includes [? David Saxton, ?] [? Emmett Kaiser ?], [? Amy McGill, ?] [? Jonathan Saltz, ?] and Steve [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. Our signers, [? Ann Delvecchio ?] and [? Molly McQuire. ?] The Black Cat Orchestra, Don Crevie, Lori Goldston, Scott Granlund, Kyle Hanson, Russell Meltzer, Matthew Sperry, [? Joseph Saenz ?].
我们的舞台工作人员包括[大卫·萨克斯顿？]、[艾米特·凯撒？]、[艾米·麦吉尔？]、[乔纳森·萨尔茨？]和史蒂夫[听不清]。我们的手语翻译：[安·德尔维奇奥？]和[莫莉·麦奎尔？]。黑猫管弦乐队：唐·克雷维、洛里·戈德斯顿、斯科特·格兰伦德、凯尔·汉森、拉塞尔·梅尔策、马修·斯佩里、[约瑟夫·萨恩兹？]。
To buy a cassette of this program or any of our shows, call us back home at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. Or you can listen to most of our programs for free on the internet at our website, www.thislife.org. Thanks to Elizabeth Meister, who runs the site.
要购买本期节目或我们任何节目的磁带，请致电我们在芝加哥的总部WBEZ，电话312-832-3380。或者你可以在我们的网站www.thislife.org上免费收听我们的大部分节目。感谢运营网站的伊丽莎白·迈斯特。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《这就是美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[赞助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who asks--
WBEZ管理监督：托里·马拉蒂亚，他问——
Admit it. Even in a pink tutu, don't I look straight?
承认吧。即使穿着粉色芭蕾舞裙，我不看起来也很直吗？
I'm Ira Glass, back next week, with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来，带来更多《这就是美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
国际公共广播电台（PRI）。